CONTROVERSIAL TRADE DEAL, ON
UNLESS MEXICO GETS TOUGHER WITH
THE BORDER.
>> Katie: JOINING US WITH MORE
INFORMATION, FOX NEWS NATIONAL
SECURITY STRATEGIST SEBASTIAN
GORKA.
MARK, I WANT TO START WITH YOU
FIRST.
WHAT IS THIS CARAVAN AND WHO ARE
THESE PEOPLE COMING TO OUR
COUNTRY?
>> THEY ARE A GROUP OF A
THOUSAND OR SO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS MOSTLY FROM HONDURAS
HAVE BEEN ORGANIZED BY A
U.S.-BASED GROUP, SAN
DIEGO-BASED ORGANIZATION, THAT
BASICALLY IS AN ANTI-BORDERS
GROUP.
WHAT WE ARE SEEING HERE IS A
KIND OF TEST OR CHALLENGE OF THE
ADMINISTRATIONS WILLINGNESS TO
ENFORCE THE LAW.
THERE ARE TWO THINGS THAT I
THE ADMINISTRATION NEEDS TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT THESE PEOPLE WILL NOT
GET PAST THE BORDER OR IF THEY
GET IN, THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
GET INTO THE INTERIOR OF THE
COUNTRY.
IF THAT REQUIRES A TEMP CITY TO
BE SET UP ON THE BORDER,
WHATEVER IT IS, THEY HAVE TO BE
KEPT WHERE THEY ARE TO SEND THE
MESSAGE THAT THIS IS NOT GOING
TO WORK.
THE OTHER THING -- AND THIS IS
SOMETHING CONGRESS HAS TO DO --
AS IT IS NOW, IF YOU ARE AN
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT AND WALK UP TO
OUR IMMIGRATION INSPECTOR AT A
BORDER, AND SAY, HI, I WANT TO
CLAIM POLITICAL ASYLUM, WE HAVE
TO TAKE THAT SERIOUSLY AND LET
YOU IN WHILE WE DO THAT CASE.
INSTEAD, WE NEED THE LAW TO
CHANGE SO THAT ANYONE WHO PASSES
THROUGH A COUNTRY THAT HAS ITS
OWN ASYLUM SYSTEM, LIKE MEXICO,
DOESN'T REALLY GET TO APPLY.
THEY JUST SAY, SORRY, TRY
MEXICO, THAT IS WHERE YOU SHOULD
HAVE SOUGHT REFUGE, YOU ARE
SUPPOSED TO LOOK FORWARD IN THE
FIRST COUNTRY YOU ARE NOT BEING
PERSECUTED IN.
>> Katie: DR. GORKA, THIS HAS
BEEN FRAMED AS ASYLUM SEEKERS
COMING TO AMERICA BECAUSE THEY
FEEL LIKE THEY ARE BEING
PERSECUTED.
THE GROUP THAT ORGANIZED THIS IS
CALLED PEOPLE WITHOUT BORDERS.
OBVIOUSLY, A LEFTIST PROGRESSIVE
GROUP TRYING TO MAKE SOME KIND
OF POLITICAL STATEMENT.
CAN YOU GIVE US PERSPECTIVE ON
HOW THIS ISN'T JUST AN
IMMIGRATION OR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION ISSUE, THIS IS A
BROADER, MORE CALM BRANDS OF
ISSUE FOR THE SOVEREIGNTY OF THE
COUNTRY?
>> ABSOLUTELY, KATIE.
ABSOLUTELY.
WHETHER IT IS CRUSHING ICES,
WHETHER IT'S TARIFFS ON ALUMINUM
OR STEEL OR WHETHER IT'S THE
WALL, THE TRUMP DOCTRINE, MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN DOCTRINE, IS
BUILT ON THE PLATFORM OF
NATIONAL SOVEREIGNTY.
THIS IS THE MOST OBVIOUS ONE.
I KNOW THIS WILL MAKE LIBERAL
MINDED PEOPLE EXPLODE BUT GUESS
WHAT, NO FOREIGN NATIONAL HAS A
RIGHT TO COME TO AMERICA.
NO ONE DOES.
IF WE DON'T HAVE BORDERS, THE
WORD AMERICA CEASES TO HAVE
MEANING.
WE NOW KNOW, THANKS TO THE
LEAKED SPEECH THAT HILLARY GAVE
DURING THE CAMPAIGN, THAT HER
WISH WAS TO HAVE A BORDERLESS
HEMISPHERE, MEANING NO BORDERS
FROM CANADA ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
CENTRAL AND SOUTH AMERICA.
IN THAT CASE, AMERICA CEASES TO
EXIST, BUT THESE PEOPLE --
HILLARY MAY HAVE LOST BUT THE
IDEOLOGUES, THE IDEOLOGICAL
ACTIVISTS, HAVEN'T GIVEN UP.
THIS IS A DIRECT THREAT TO
NATIONAL SECURITY BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T HAVE A POROUS BORDER AND
KEEP AMERICANS SAFE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER THESE
PEOPLE WANT ASYLUM.
THAT BORDER IS THERE TO PROTECT
US FROM DRUGS, FROM COYOTES,
FROM ILLEGAL WEAPONS.
GUESS WHAT?
FROM TERRORISTS AS WELL.
>> Katie: MARKHAM I WANT TO GO
BACK TO THE POINT YOU MADE ABOUT
HOW THE LAW AND AMERICA IS
WORKING AGAINST US HERE.
IT AN ILLEGAL ALIEN IS FROM
MEXICO OR CANADA, WE CAN SEND
THEM BACK BUT IF THEY ARE
FROM HONDURAS, EL SALVADOR, AND
OTHER OTHER COUNTRIES, WE HAVE
TO PUT THEM INTO OUR COURT
SYSTEM, WHICH THE MAJORITY
OF THEM DO NOT SHOW UP TO.
HOW CAN CONGRESS ACT TO CHANGE
THIS SO WE HAVE MORE CONTROL OF
WHO COMES IN AND OUT OF THE
COUNTRY?
>> THE DIFFICULTY IN SENDING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS BACK WHO
AREN'T FROM MEXICO OR CANADA,
OBVIOUSLY MOSTLY FROM MEXICO,
NOT
NOT TOO MANY CANADIANS SNEAKING
ACROSS THE BORDER, IS THAT WITH
A MEXICAN, WE JUST TAKE THEM TO
THE BORDER, THE MEXICAN
AUTHORITIES WORK WITH US.
THEY DO COOPERATE WITH US PRETTY
WELL AND WE WILL SEND THEM BACK.
ANYONE BEYOND THAT,
CENTRAL AMERICA, AFRICA, ASIA,
THOSE PEOPLE NEED TRAVEL
DOCUMENTS, PASSPORTS, THEY GOT
TO BE FLOWN THERE, A LOT OF
STUFF.
A LOT OF PEACEFUL, COUNTRIES
BASICALLY DRAG THEIR FEET OR REF
BASICALLY DRAG THEIR FEET OR RES
BASICALLY DRAG THEIR FEET OR RED
BASICALLY DRAG THEIR FEET OR RET
BASICALLY DRAG THEIR FEET OR REO
TAKE PEOPLE BACK.
>> Katie: BUT ABOUT THE FACT
THAT COYOTES, DRUG CARTELS,
CORRUPT MEMBERS OF GOVERNMENT,
THESE MIGRANTS ARE PASSING
THROUGH ON THEIR WAY TO THE
U.S., ARE BEING TRAINED TO SAY
THAT THEY ARE SEEKING ASYLUM
BECAUSE THEY FEEL LIKE THEIR
LIVES ARE ENDANGERED.
WHAT ABOUT CHANGES TO THE LAW
LIKE THE TRAFFICKING VICTIMS
PROTECTION ACT?
OBVIOUSLY THAT LAW HAD GOOD
INTENTIONS AS IT WAS IMPLEMENTED
IN 2008 BUT NOW WE ARE SEEING IT
BEING ABUSED OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, FOR EXAMPLE IT WAS ABUSED
IN 2014 DURING THE CHILD
IMMIGRATION CRISIS THEN.
HOW CAN CONGRESS WORK TODAY TO
ACTUALLY MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
CAN JUST SAY THEY ARE SEEKING
ASYLUM WHEN THERE IS NO
BACKGROUND CHECK TO PROVE THAT
THEY ARE ACTUALLY HERE FOR THAT
REASON?
>> THERE IS NO WAY TO PREVENT
REALLY.
IT'S NOT AS THOUGH SOMEBODY
PERSECUTING YOU IS GOING TO SEND
YOU AN AFFIDAVIT SAYING, YES, I
PERSECUTED YOU.
THAT ALLOW YOU REFER TO, THE
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS PROTECTION
ACT, IS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
MINORS, AND WHO ARE TRAFFIC.
IT'S A JARGON TERM BUT IF YOU
ARE SMUGGLED, THAT MEANS YOU ARE
DOING IT VOLUNTARILY.
YOU PAY, YOUR PARENTS PAID YOU
TO BE SMUGGLED.
TRAFFIC IS SOME KIND OF COERCION
OR TRICKERY.
YOU ARE BEING USED FOR SEX
SLAVERY OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION USED
THE LAW, THAT AS YOU SUGGESTED,
IS A WELL-INTENTIONED LAW, BUT
MISUSED IT AND SAID, THESE
PEOPLE ARE ALL BEING TRAFFIC SO
WE WILL LET THEM ALL IN.
THAT POINTS TO A PROBLEM THAT
CONGRESS CAN'T SEE AND FIX EVERY
EVENTUALITY.
IT DOES SORT OF MATTER WHO
IMPLEMENTS THE LAW.
IF YOU HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION
LIKE THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION,
THEY WILL TAKE WHATEVER LAW,
HOWEVER IT'S WRITTEN, AND
DISTORTED AND INTERPRETED ANYWAY
THEY WANT.
>> Katie: DR. GORKA, CONGRESS
DOESN'T WANT TO SEEM TO MOVE ON
ANYTHING WHEN IT COMES TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, CRIMINAL
ALIENS.
WHAT CAN THE PRESIDENT TO IN
TERMS OF HIS LEVERAGE WITH
MEXICO?
E THROUGHOUT THE IDEA OF NAFTA
BEING A NEGOTIATING PEACE, TO
ENCOURAGE MEXICO TO HELP US
STOP ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HE WILL DO
GOING FORWARD TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS IS A HOT ISSUE AND IT'S A
BIG REASON WHY HE WON?
>> IT'S NOT THAT CONGRESS ISN'T
DOING ANYTHING.
HALF OF THEM ARE ACTUALLY MAKING
IT EASIER TO UNDERMINE THE
NATIONAL SOVEREIGNTY.
LET'S LOOK AT THE RECENT HUBBUB
ON THE CENSUS.
THE DEMOCRATS WERE SCREAMING
BLUE MURDER BECAUSE WE WANT TO
KNOW IF YOU ARE HERE AS A
CITIZEN OR NOT, AND THEN THEY
SHOUTED, BUT THAT'S GOING TO
LEAD TO VOTER SUPPRESSION.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN, KATIE?
WHOSE VOTES ARE WE GOING TO
SUPPRESS IF WE ASK -- ONLY ONE
GROUP OF PEOPLE.
ILLEGAL ALIENS.
SO HALF OF CONGRESS WANTS TO SEE
THESE WAYS, THE DEMOCRATS ARE
LOSING THE WHITE VOTE IN
AMERICA, THE MIDDLE CLASS, THE
WORKING CLASS VOTE.
THEY THINK THE HISPANIC VOTE IS
THE FUTURE.
SO THEY ARE ACTIVELY UNDERMINING
THE PRESIDENT AND OUR NATIONAL
SOVEREIGNTY.
THE PRESIDENT COULD DO A LOT OF
THINGS WITH HIS EXECUTIVE
ORDERS.
WE'VE GOT TO STOP THE CATCH AND
RELEASE.
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN MORE THAN A
70% DECREASE IN ILLEGAL
MIGRATION ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDERS.
ALLOWING OUR CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PATROL TO DO THEIR JOB HELPS A
LOT.
BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
>> Katie: MARK, ISN'T THIS A
TEST FOR THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IN TERMS OF HOW
THEY REACT?
THEY KNOW THIS GROUP OF 1,000
PLUS PEOPLE IS COMING.
THE WAY THAT THEY REACT IS
PROBABLY GOING TO BE WATCHED BY
A NUMBER OF OTHER PEOPLE WHO ARE
MAY BE PLANNING ON PULLING ONE
OF THESE POLITICAL STUNTS, AS
WELL.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS IS PROBABLY THE MOST
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF WHAT WE ARE
SEEING WITH THIS CARAVAN, IS
THAT IT IS TEST AND AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION.
ARE THEY GOING TO REACT THE WAY